more and more people are developing
cataracts as they age typically what a
person will do is though they may get
surgery well sometimes there are
complications to that surgery it's not a
complication free or side effect free
surgical procedure I mean in one study
42 percent of people who get cataracts
develop dry eyes a 20 get the droopy
eyelid and there's other complications
like floaters so personally I would try
more of a natural route first since they
have very little side effects people
will say well where's the scientific
studies there's no studies that validate
using this natural remedy which
basically cost enemies that can
potentially help you there's not a lot
of science-based evidence to show that
that's going to be effective well guess
what I have news for you there won't be
who's going to invest the thousands or
tens of thousands or even millions of
dollars
on studies that involve natural remedies
it's not going to happen you can't
patent these things instead why don't we
take a look at the mechanism of what
causes a cloudy lens which is a cataract
and then use some type of natural remedy
that makes sense that really has very
minimal downsides compare two drugs and
surgery the first thing you should know
about the eye is this it's one of those
tissues that is highly affected by
blood sugars your blood sugars are high
the eye is very vulnerable to high
sugars because when the sugar is high it
creates a tremendous amount of oxidation
or oxidative stress and so that is the
one thing that we know about cataracts
and you can think of oxidative stress as
something rusting out so let's say for
example you have your car and it has
rust spots because of all the salt on
the roads whatever if you're raised in
some place like Wisconsin which gets
really cold and so we have to put a lot
of the salt on the road to melt the snow
it can also create chemical reactions
with the metal in your car and it can
actually rust out the same thing
happening with the eyes in relationship
to diabetes and pre-diabetes and just
having a high carb diet you get this
chemical reaction that creates a lot of
damage especially as we age because of
this our bodies produce something called
endogenous antioxidants those are
antioxidants that our body makes to
protect against all this oxidation and
free radical damage as we age we make
less of those antioxidants and also if
our diet is not right or we consume a
bit too many carbs things can definitely
go south in the area of vision and eyes
including age-related macular
degeneration is in difficulty seeing at
night now we can tap into Mother Nature
into various plants to use some of their
compounds that they have developed or
eons of time in the area of plant
pigments those pigments that make up
certain colors and these pigments are
very potent antioxidants they have
anti-inflammatory properties and they
can help counter the effects of this
oxidative stress especially in the lens
of the eye and the two categories of
these pigments that I want to mention
are one carotenoids okay which include
like beta-carotene which is the
precursor for vitamin okay it's not the
active form it has to be converted into
Vitamin A only animal products have the
active form and then you have also other
types of carotenoids called lutein and
zeaxanthin which are more known for the
age-related macular degeneration and so
the color of carotenoids would be like
the yellow the orange the red
purple vegetables and even you find
these in egg yolks which are yellow but
you also find these in grass-fed meat as
well which is interesting simply because
cows eat grass which has an abundant
supply of carotenoids but you're not
going to nearly find the quantities in
like grain fed beef that the
conventional beef that you would get at
the grocery store same thing with eggs
you know like if you get a pasta raised
organic chicken eggs much higher
carotenoids now it is true that
conventional eggs do have these
carotenoids but there's a dirty little
secret that they can give these chickens
synthetic pigments
because they're confined to huge Barns
and are fed grains that have very little
pigment left but there's another
category of pigments that I'm going to
focus in on and that's called
anthocyanins and so the color of these
anthocyanins would be like the red
a purple
and the blue and this pigment has quite
an effect on your eyes especially if
there's oxidative stress and it may help
reduce the risk cataracts and
potentially even reverse cataracts if
you catch it early enough so this is
like the active compound in bilberry it
can help recycle something called
rhodopsin which actually can help you
see in the dark it can also reduce the
risk of age-related macular degeneration
it can relax the ciliary muscle that is
connected to the lens that is usually
strained when you're doing a lot of
computer work or reading for a long
periods of time so it can help take the
strain out of the eye and it has been
known to help with cataracts and a lot
of other plants are also loaded with
anthocyanins as well so we have the
bilberry we have the blueberry we have
the Blackberry we even have red cabbage
and by the way is a side note the red
cabbage Sprouts are way higher in this
anthocyanthems than adult cabbage but
out of all the plants the choke Berry is
the highest now the remedy that I'm
going to recommend to help potentially
decrease the risk of cataracts it's
going to be a shake it's going to be
composed of berries
as well as kefir because kefir also has
some interesting things in it that can
also help reduce the risk of cataracts
and one being dietary calcium there's
definitely this association between
getting enough calcium from dairy and
having less
cataracts then you also have all the
probiotics in kefir which by the way is
way more than yogurt and there's even
some interesting studies on yogurt
helping with cataracts well Kefir is
much stronger than yogurt kefir also can
help with other things like infections
in the eye like pink eye and anytime you
do in kefir I highly recommend that you
get the unsweetened version of kefir
get the whole milk kefir not the low fat
and make sure the Kefir is from
grass-fed animals whether it's a goat
sheep or cow so you're simply going to
mix one cup of berries with one cup of
beefer and you'll blend it up
and you'll drink it down now sometimes
the Kefir is pretty thick so in that
case you might have to add a little bit
of water to thin it out or you can just
consume it with a spoon now the question
is what kind of berries should you use
you can really just use any of the
berries because they're all pretty high
in anthocyanins and what you'll do is
you just take a cup of that mix it with
the kefir
blend it up and consume that once a day
combination of this high quality kefir
with this
anthocyanin Rich Berry mix is going to
produce a really cool effect on your
eyes and not just for the lens but for
the macular which is the back part of
the eye and the other tissues it could
help counter some of the complications
of all this oxidative stress now
parallel with this I would definitely
make sure that your diet is very low in
sucrose fructose and I would not
actually recommend consuming milk okay
because that also has lactose in it as
well but when you have a fermented milk
product that's going to be a lot better
now there's some other things that you
can do okay
there's a nutritional remedy called NAC
in a drop form that you can use on your
eyes and the NAC remedy I'm going to
recommend is kind of confusing because
there's two types of NAC out there one
is n acetyl carnosine and that's the one
that you want you don't want to get the
n-acetyl cysteine
okay now that's good for other things
like addictions especially a fatty liver
but the one for the eye and acetyl
carnosine is very specific as an
antioxidant
to help reduce cataracts now the
carnosine that acts as an antioxidant
can't really penetrate the surface of
the eye and that's why this other
compound is added to carnosine the N
acetyl part of this compound that allows
it to penetrate into the first chamber
of the eye and that's where the lens is
so it can do its work so these NAC drops
are another thing you can add to the
protocol I would also recommend
consuming eggs especially the egg yolks
and make sure that they're runny as well
because egg yolks are just loaded with
carotenoids which is good for the eye as
well as anthocyanins
as well as something else called oline
and choline has some additional cool
effects to counter dry eyes now let's
say for example
you already have the cataracts okay and
you have complications is there anything
that can be done for that and the answer
is potentially yes
there's another product that you can get
called
oculotrophin PMG it's from a company
called Standard Process I'm not
affiliated with that company but
that's something I used to use in
practice for anything related to
post-surgical in the eye
or injury to the eye
so if you've scratched your eye if you
had some type of eye damage that's a
really good product to help you now
there's some other things you should
know that go beyond just this remedy for
cataracts and I think you really like
what I have to add about cataracts in
this video right here